seen these before oh my gosh have i ever
oh okay so you know your questions are
amazing
let me surprise you and my answers are
better so let's go
all right ingrid uh where are you from
where'd you grow up
grew up born and raised in los angeles
south central or south central south
central yeah but went to school in west
l.a
uh hollywood and west la my parents
never
kept me in south central as far as
school is concerned so central is a
rough neighborhood to grow up in right i
mean it is but i grew up right around
the corner actually across the street
for
from uh where one of the they call them
fabulous for something fantastic for
the guys that
beat reginald denning like yeah for some
reason that's the title for the fourth
it's a rough neighborhood but yeah
i forgot about it i grew up with them in
my surroundings
yeah
how would you describe your childhood
yeah
um my parents my parents were fabulous
um
great parents
um
didn't
love each other for the most part
my mother was
in love with my father
my dad
did not
he was not he was a great provider
not a very good husband but always a
great father and a great provider he was
kind of promiscuous
and actually rather promiscuous and
found that out very early not by way of
him doing anything towards me but just
he you know my sister i'm the youngest
and uh the the closest to me in age is
15 years older
so when i'm 8 you know
plus 15 i mean you know my brother my
siblings are already in their 20s
so um it's
it's um
you know it was it was very like lonely
i guess per se i had my friends you know
cousins and stuff but i was kind of a
loner but yeah my parents they were
awesome parents my dad gave me
everything i wanted my mom
she you know i they were older
but i i learned how to play them against
each other to get anything i wanted and
to be whoever i wanted to be
i was very confused growing up i went
through an identity crisis
i
really didn't even know that there was
different races until i was in junior
high school first time i ever heard
somebody say the word [ __ ] but i was
in seventh grade and which is crazy when
you grow up on manchester normandy like
when is that like that's
yeah it's kind of weird but um
anyway
never knew anything about drugs
and different things i found out later
that my family had some association with
drugs but
it was never associated with me i just
i smoked weed growing up like
12 years old started drinking smoking
weed
and just never
thought you know anything could really
conquer me
started doing powder not until i was in
my 20s
and uh next thing you know it was like
wow here's you know some powder mixed
with baking soda and water and who would
have known the difference that it made
in a person's life
it made a big difference it took my kids
it took my family
it took me for me
i went to college
everything that i would have wanted
growing up i was given
and everything i could have had i
had the opportunity to get
and
the only thing that bothers me is my
parents passing
before
they saw me do something different with
my life
my father passed away
in
2018 and my mother passed away in 2019
and
[Music]
you know i went through a lot of abuse
with relationships
um my son's father my i have a daughter
and a son my daughter is ninth well
she's 18. she'll be 19 next year but yes
he's 18. my son is um my son is nine and
i i actually was a mom to her at some
point in time
and i know a lot of these girls on the
street a lot of these women on the
street they never
they have kids they don't have the
opportunity to be a parent
and
it hurts for us that have been that
parent
it's painful
when you have your child
like taken from you but at the same time
it's the realization the real
comfort in it is knowing their safety
because of where you could have sent
them and brought them
dragging them into your life
style with you
i didn't start
being on the street
um
you know when i started doing drugs like
hard drugs
um i had money
and it wasn't a problem it was during
like the whole economic breakdown time
and all that
so i was going through i had hey you
know about like
six thousand coming in a month five
thousand coming in a month so it was
like okay you know i can just i could
splurge a little bit and you know it's
not big big huge money but
for just somebody working a regular nine
to five it was like still nice to not
have to work and you're just getting
free money
and um
you know i didn't realize
what i was pulling myself into or
allowing myself to go into
i thought i could conquer
everything
and
it's like people say drugs
when you do drugs you do them because
you are
trying to
hinder your mind from something painful
that you've gone through
um
maybe in some cases i think for most
or for actually yeah for most it's more
or less you think you have the ability
to conquer everything i think the
hindrance comes during the process of
doing them
you know i mean
hey baby
once you
go through the effect of losing your
children and different things like that
those are the things that make you
hurt can i have my liquor please
oh he was emptying my glass oh he's such
a sweetheart
but you know but yeah but then um
i met the streets and didn't know
anything about the streets and the
streets hurt me a lot they made me
realize a lot but they built me up a lot
and i am thank you back and i'm grateful
for the fact that
every trial i've gone through
has only made me stronger it's made me
in some way shape or form smile through
all the pain and the tears and it made
me meet the love of my life you know
and um
that's who he is
you
know the love of my life
you want to say hi
poke your head in the camera
you've been on my channel before
love of my life new york
and he it's crazy because you know
he met me on the street
so you had a good childhood my childhood
my i had a very comfortable childhood
how does a girl that has childhood like
that end up in the streets
um
thinking she can run everything
i thought i could control everything i
could run everything i have a [ __ ] i
have a college degree i mean it's like i
went to college i did i did what you
would expect for a person to do
like
with
parents that
built them in that manner but when i was
two i was molested
i just recently found that out but um
when i was six years old i was molested
by i took piano lessons for 14 years
and my piano teacher
i started that i started private lessons
with at six years old
molested me and
i don't remember it
i remember one day
seeing him
and
i was 18 years old and i was already in
my second year of college because i
graduated from high school at 16.
and
i saw him and
my uh my mom said ooh look come see
who's at the front door it was during my
spring like summer break
and i saw him
and face to face i just i peed on myself
and
i didn't know why i didn't know why i
was what the hell like
dude i'm 18 years old what the [ __ ] is
going on here when i went to sleep that
night i had a flashback of just him
behind me with like
jacking off behind me while i was
sitting at the piano and me turning
around and i just remembered that
terrifying feeling that i felt
and i don't know how long it went on i
have no clue to this day how long it
went on
i don't know what else he had done to me
i don't know why i felt like it was such
a bad thing for me to see
you know because when you're six if you
turn around and you see somebody doing
something you you'd probably be like
what is he doing and turn back around
you know
and that made me wonder
and i found out a few years later
that
the preschool i went to
i was two years old it was around the
corner from my house it was a cult
i would i would say the name but i don't
want to put names out to your lifetime
but um
the school
i don't know what happened
but my mom said after the third day
she knew she could never send me back
there again
and she didn't know why she said i would
hold on to the top of the car
and to the point my fingernails were
bleeding
so i would not go back
please mommy no mommy no mommy two years
old
and when she told me that i said it had
to have happened to me before
somebody had to have done that to me
then
and um it was it's a friend of mine well
she's not a friend of mine she's an
associate i'm figueroa and you know it's
crazy because god puts us i'm i'm i was
born and raised in church
god puts us in some situations that
we don't even know he's going to put us
in or why
or where we're going to be and it's so
amazing to me
and i praise him for and i'm grateful
for it i'm grateful for
every
bad experience every
everybody i met
i've only been arrested
one time never for her prostitute never
liked anything
but the day that i got arrested
which was actually two probably two
months ago
um
it was a
girl that stays right down the street
from me at a motel
and i don't know what made me bring it
up but i brought up that story
and she said oh girl she said it was a
lady that
i
that that babysat me
when i was about three four years old
she said up until i was about eight
she said and she molested me in her name
and she gave me her name and it was the
same lady whose school i went to
and i knew right then that that's what
happened to me when i was two
and
it i was the first kid to get to the
school the only people there was the
owner of the school and the security
guard
and i don't know what happened i was two
years old you know
but
i know my childhood doctor always told
me she well she would even tell my
parents she said
she said something happened to her i
don't know what but
but you know it's once again it's a
reason why god puts you in certain
places
and um
i'm the black sheep of the family per se
but
um for my mom's children
however
i miss my mom
she was my best friend
she knew everything even me being on the
street she knew everything about me
you know i miss my kids
my daughter she's 18 my son is nine
but i miss my babies
i miss being a mom i hate drugs
okay
i'm okay
you know
thank you
it's like the people i met
half these [ __ ] on figaro can't stand
me
you know
and the one i feel closest to me the a
few of them i feel close to me
out of them
a couple of them have done me really bad
and really dirty and i've done
a couple of them really dirty
and
but
the one thing i would say is
you know we just
we don't understand how much we connect
we really know
regardless of our background regardless
of where we've been it ain't no boozy
[ __ ] and they know whole [ __ ] and they
know ghetto shape is us
because we came together
regardless why are we together only
because of god god put us together
and like
to not get that is like stupidity
it really is
yeah
so yeah any more questions
oh i love my little swing in the chair
[Laughter]
but i've seen a lot of commenters on my
channel complain about
my uh so what would you like to
revolving chair
but i think it it's therapeutic for
people whenever i know i love it
plus i was in modern like hey i went to
i was in modern jazz i did all that i
was a cheerleader
i'm a vocal coach and
like i said i play piano like i take
like 14 plus years lessons
i have so many trophies it's stupid
i was in w times i was in pageants i was
like i said
college and so your perfect childhood
had some dark spots
um i mean there is no such thing as a
perfect childhood you know
and i mean it's like like the school i
went to
uh all my friends that like i went
trick-or-treating in bel air but i lived
on 83rd in normandy so it's like i mean
it's like
that's a big difference
they're opposites yeah very opposite but
i mean the the i was a cheerleader my
daughter she was a cheerleader
um i hate the pain i put her through
more than anything
i would say um i hate that my son has
never really had stability
and i hate that it's all because of my
life style that i chose to be selfish
with
um
and i hate even more that even as i
change
my progression has not been faster or
quicker by way of them being in a better
position
or mindset or comfortability you know i
mean
my son's father
the things that the pain i endured by
with him abuse why i had never been in a
fight in my life until i was in my 30s
and
that was when
he hit me for the first time
and
knocked my eye on my socket
i was temporarily blind
out of your socket
my eye was dislocated in three three
places this eye right here that's why it
stays black
yes sorry
yeah and yeah i know you had a black eye
but
that's not from recently i i will tell
you like this
since in the past okay i'm 41
so since i was 30 years old i never had
a fight before i was 30 in my life
since i was 30 i've been shot twice i've
had my head busted open uh
hit in the head 20 times with a 10 pound
weight
by someone who later on became a
roommate of mine a very close friend of
mine and i still love her to death like
a sister how weird is that
let's see i've had about probably
15 bones broken fingers hands feet even
this foot right here
my foot is tough my bone sticks out on
the bottom
and
now we're talking about a girl who is
like shoot
just
my eye has been knocked out the top my
nose has been broke four times
um
my daughter and my mother have both seen
me drug down the street by my hair these
are all hazards of the uh the occupation
here and the crazy no and that's the
crazy thing all of that was before i
even well i'll say
okay up until
the shooting okay
the eye socket
the um
nose the breaks in the hand
and
the
yeah probably that all of that was
beforehand
really the only thing that's happened
since then is the head
isn't that crazy
um i didn't start dating until
like wow i haven't been dating but i'm
41. i haven't been dating but for about
[ __ ] maybe eight seven not even seven
years
um
one day my son's father told me
we were smoking crack and he said
it
he said leave and when you go
come back
with some money wear some dope
or don't come back at all and that was
during the 100 day 100 nights thing that
they had going on whatever that was i
can't remember how long ago it was and
um
that was the first date i ever had
and i went and this guy said i'll give
you 250
for 20 minutes
and that was the first date i ever had
and that was so to me so degrading
because putting a price tag on yourself
is so
but i didn't want to be outside i had no
shoes on i had no clothes on i had
a shirt a t-shirt
and it was pouring down rain
and i would never forget that night
but
that night changed my life in a very big
way
it made me never have to ask anyone for
anything ever again
without me realizing
she never had to ask anybody for
anything anyway you got a college degree
you got this and that going for you like
all you got to do is put a pipe down
you know but
life life shows that
i always tell people one thing
i say my biggest thing
is
just
remember
you know
oh shoot i almost made it
no
my my biggest thing is this like
always remember
you never want to wake up and wonder
what yesterday looked like
that's just the biggest thing and and
also
everything isn't not yet
everything in life for anybody isn't it
i never thought hell i didn't even know
what cocaine looked like until i took a
snort
and i was in my third like i was like no
i was about 27
but i mean really
cocaine or alcohol bigger
oh my god alcohol is my number one i
love to drink i love to drink and it
scared me because my daughter told me
one day she said
she said mom what scares me
is when you drink and i never thought of
it like that but my mom
until i was about eight years old my mom
was an alcoholic and one day she just
became a church-a-holic but
you know
but uh which is i'm grateful for but i
remember being very scared
you know
just little flashes of just being scared
but she was abused in her previous
marriage the marriage previous to my
father
and um
you know she
that's how she dealt with it
and
i noticed like that's how i dealt with
my pain
you know my grandmother she she drank
my grandmother was german and spaniard
she was very racist
she she sold my parents my mom you know
my dad i never met his his parents
because my parents were like
my
my dad was born in 35 my mom was born in
45 so i mean it's like you know i was
literally like the unexpected surprise
you know beautiful surprise but
yeah i've talked a lot
the alcohols would lead you the alcohol
addiction is probably in the crack
alcohol but
alcohol alcohol is like
what makes everything okay
what makes it seem like everything
alcohol makes you forget
it it makes me forget
it puts it puts a smile it's what makes
it
easy to do
anything and i mean like i said i'm not
on the streets right now but like you
know i mean alcohol makes it very easy
to
suffice to
giving yourself
and your all
when
really you don't have to
you know it makes it makes the pain go
away
better to me than drugs
and that's why it scares me
because um it and it runs in my family
alcoholism like
it's a it's a big thing in my family but
i'm
it's it i would say if i had a drug of
choice it's alcohol all the time yeah
what's your biggest regret in your life
my biggest regret
is my now
um
i regret
that
i know
what
i should do when i walk out this door
that i know what i should do when i walk
in my house
that i know what i should do on sunday
morning
that i know what i should do every night
every day and don't do it just
let go
just accept
just really
humble myself to my enemy my worst fear
which is my mind
that is my regret that i don't humble
myself to my mind
it's a dangerous thing
and i i'm very scared that
i don't think my demise will ever be
crack cocaine
i don't think my demise will be alcohol
but i think my demise
will just be
however i don't want to be maimed
because of my choices
you know i don't want to be
like
i don't want to stop
because it's something that has to
happen so i can survive and live
on a you know just a
just a life that's not
free
you know
destructive streak
um i i
i honestly believe i am
um
i'm scared
i'm scared as [ __ ]
i'm scared
i'm scared of what
what's going
when my daughter will become
what she i don't think she would turn to
the streets but
just
the pain
if anything if she lost me the pain
my son i never had my son you know i
love my son
and my son loves me
i'm sorry
but
[Music]
my son is
my baby but my daughter is my heart
she's my soul
and it's not to pick one over the other
but i watched her take a first step i
saw her potty trained
i saw her
you know
first day of school
and to hurt her
hurts me so much
and what hurts me more is the fact that
i don't stop hurting her
and she's so strong
damn
[Music]
i lost her because
i tested positive
well my son tested positive
for
cocaine and his system when he was born
and it took me
years to admit that i smoked in my
pregnancy
or that i did drugs and
you know i could have killed my my son i
could have killed him
that's crazy
kind of parent does that
so those are the things that kind of
make me suffice to
drinking more and more going on the
street just you know just not um
not even going on the street but
drinking you know which leads to
uncareless
decisions and
you know my thing is i never looked at
it as hoeing or you know i always like
that as entertainment with benefits
because i wanted to hear i was pretty i
wanted somebody tell me i was pretty and
stuff like that like putting a price tag
on yourself how do you put a price tag
on priceless like i'm priceless but
so
like that part was like crazy to me
you know i take donations baby
you get addicted to this lifestyle
you get addicted to this lifestyle
well it's not even enough to get a
dictate it's easy it's easy easy money
easy
you know
yeah but that that leads to the
you're addicted
[Laughter]
okay so look
so
i was on western
i remember it was a guy that i that i
used to buy drugs from and he told me
one day he said i'm not your man he said
you want to get some money shoot you did
it once before and this was after
everything happened with you know baby
daddy and putting me out there and
all that and
um it became the entertainment money
you know i was making money i could pay
my rent all that but i couldn't afford
rent and this and my habit you can't
afford rent and i have it like that's a
lot like
car no habit jesus christ and bills oh
wow like that's a lot because what
happened when i went to my first program
they have you break down how much you
spend
and it's crazy i i spent 400
to six
minimum 400 a day on crack cocaine
and i'm a chick with no job
how do you spend
that every [ __ ] day
what what does that like it's like and
they make you they make you multiply it
by seven
okay so now we add 28 then they make you
multiply the 28 by just like god damn
like i don't even want to do i don't
want your math anymore how much money
would i have a year from not smoking you
know so that means how much of my body
am i giving up
you know how much of my soul am i giving
you know the what my parents put so much
effort into and before my mother died
my son's father this is the coldest
thing ever
my son's father told her my mom had
stage four cancer
and
she she had her son since birth
he called her and said hey he was mad at
me hey you ever want to find your
daughter just go on western
any black you'll probably see her
jumping out of the car getting in one
she asked me about it she said
he told me something
i don't want to believe it
she said but if it's true you will never
see your children again
she said i just don't believe it and she
told i knew what she was gonna say and
she told me and i hung up the phone from
her and i called her the next morning
and i told her it was true
and i said mom you're my best friend
you don't deserve to think anything
less of being that i said however
because it's something that was brought
to you i mean my mom died like a month
and a half later like i mean it's like
she died
feeling like
her baby was old
by way of a man
who
she was taking care of his child since
birth my mom was 73 years old when she
died
there's no reason why she had to raise a
child
my son being none right now my mom died
in 2019 hello do the math
seven years
she had her son
and that's what you chose to tell her
but i don't hate him
i i pity him
i pity his choices
and i've never blamed him even though
he's the first person
who ever said if you don't bring a rock
or a dollar back
same one who knocked my eye out the
socket
the same man that drug me down the
street by my hair
someone my daughter
cries every day because she he's has my
son right now
and won't even let me talk to my son on
the phone
to this day
because my sister
just
couldn't do it no more she had my son
after my mom died she can't do it no
more
and
because he has certain opportunities i
don't that would give my son a better
privilege
it was a better option and because of
that
i have to go into a program and i will
go
i'm going
actually
very soon
yeah me maybe that'll be my second
interview
[Laughter]
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
everything is not yet
nobody is any better you know there is
no such thing as never everything is a
not yet
even if you never go through it you know
it's like just knowing that this person
that's right here even around the corner
from us is no different than me i could
have on high heels maybe i've been out
here i lived in cars i've lived in tents
i've done all that
but my god is good you know but
humbleness
being humble like that's the key
humility
like
just really realizing what is the bigger
picture you know
looking at the whole
like
like they say in program they say play
out the whole tape
you know
and understand that insanity is not only
doing the same thing except in a
different result but also realizing that
you
are the different result in yourself not
the situation
changing yourself
you know
insanity is insanity but people look at
it as everything other than them
that's what's crazy we always look at
insanity as everything other than us now
we are the insane one we are the one
that keeps repeating the same thing they
say repeating the same action expecting
a different result
people look at it as oh yeah i'm
repeating the same action walking into
it instead of realizing no you're going
into it the exact same way idiot it's
not everybody else it's you
dum yummy
but god is good hey life is great you
know
i don't honestly
when you say regret i don't regret it
because it made me strong
um i love
i love some of the people i've grown
very close to what you've met some of
them but i really really
have grown a strong appreciation for
truth
and um
understanding
you know
there's no mistakes in life you know
there's only there's only
growth you know i mean hell we we
when age comes wisdom i'm getting older
that's all i can appreciate so god is
good hey
all right mark
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you you're very interested
you